Melania Trump accused of plagiarizing
Michelle Obama when Donald Trump's wife
took the stage at the 2016 Republican
National Convention Monday night parts
of her speech sounded awfully familiar
to FLOTUS his speech from the 2008
National Convention we want our children
and all children in this nation to know
that the only limit to the height of
your achievements is the reach of your
dreams and your willingness to work hard
for them because we want our children in
this nation to know that the only limit
to your achievements is the strength of
your dreams and your willingness to work
for them Brock and I were raised with so
many of the same values like you work
hard for what you want in life that your
word is your bond that you do what you
say you're going to do my parents
impressed on me the values that you work
hard for what you want in life that your
word is your bond and you do what you
say and keep your promise it's hard to
deny that Melania or at least her speech
writer was heavily inspired by
Michelle's words the Trump campaign
later responded to the accusations in
writing her beautiful speech milania's
team of writers took notes on her life's
inspirations and in some instances
included fragments that reflected her
own thinking milania's immigrant
experience and love for America shone
through in her speech which made it such
a success
you